tell me the one safety deemed such
destruction this is the one that you
hunted then saved yes the one that saved
me as well from the matterhorn yes it
looks hopeless it's injured but it is
not helpless its species can move
objects with its mind I know of such
things the songs of eons past tell them
battles between Mandalore the Great and
an order of sorcerers called Jedi that
fought with such powers it is an enemy
no its kind were enemies but this
individual is not what is it
it is a foundling
by Creed it is in your care so wish me
to train this thing it is too weak it
would die you have no choice you must
reunite it with its own kind where this
you must determine you're expected to
search the galaxy for the home of his
creature and deliver it to a race of
enemy sorcerers this is the way
welcome back everyone its charlie Happy
New Year this is gonna be my new
Mandalorian season 2 video and talking
about the ancient Jedi Mandalorian Wars
and why they're referencing them so
heavily during this scene here it's all
connected to stuff that they're trying
to seed and world build within the Star
Wars universe because the next Star Wars
movie is supposed to be set during the
past also reference that during the
video too because there's been some news
about that if you're new to my channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
Mandalorian videos I'll be doing bonus
videos until we get to season 2 episodes
we're doing a merch giveaway - all you
have to do to enter is be subscriber and
leave all your predictions about season
2 on the video
so obviously careful for spoilers for
everything from the Mandalorian season
one because we'll be talking about this
scene and some other things that they
referenced also what's going on with the
dark saber so her line about ancient
Jedi sorcerers is the throwback line to
the Knights of the Old Republic era a
great series of multiple wars between
the Mandalorian clans and the Jedi Order
and also did that funny Han Solo
reference from a new hope when he refers
to hokey religions and ancient weapons
things echoing back thousands of years
in the Star Wars timeline that we
haven't really seen in the movies yet
but did they sort of teed up a little
bit recently what does this mean for
season two episodes and obviously what
does this have to do with the new Star
Wars movie that was just announced so
when the Mandalorian bulks at his
mission as she gives it to him and you
want me to hand him over to enemy
sorcerers she notes that they're not
enemies right now the Jedi aren't their
enemies in present-day they were a long
time ago in a galaxy far far away the
actual Mandalorian Jedi war she speaks
of were fought between four and five
thousand years ago it was started by a
group of sword-wielding Mandalorians
called the Mandalorian Crusaders and
around that time was also when the dark
saber was created so no coincidence that
you see it appear during the end of
season 1 obviously it's more relevant to
what's happening in present-day but
they're sort of connecting the Star Wars
timeline with all these references and
easter eggs so also no coincidence that
they referenced the Jedi Mandalorian
Wars from thousands of years ago on the
Clone Wars series when they introduced
the dark saber for the first time on
that series for generations my ancestors
fought proudly as warriors against the
Jedi
now that woman tarnishes the very name
Mandalorian this lightsaber was stolen
from your Jedi Temple by my ancestors
during the fall of the Old Republic if
you didn't watch that series that was
actually Jon Favreau's Pre Vizsla
character so he also played a character
during the Mandalorians season one he
just did a voiceover he wasn't
underneath that armor but the character
he was playing on the Mandalorian Sirius
was also a member of previz TLAs house
those were the Death Watch Mandalorians
on that series we also saw a live-action
version of the Death Watch Mandalorians
in the flashback they were the ones that
saved Jin Gerak's Mandalorian character
when he was a child during the Clone
Wars when the droids came to attack see
how it's all connected
but the Mandalorians that fought with
the Jedi were called the Mandalorian
Crusaders they wielded swords they were
actually started as an organization by
Mandalore the first the person who's
known for conquering the great mythos or
that they also referenced during the
Mandalorian episode - also connecting
these Easter eggs and references to
what's happening in the Star Wars movie
is going forward after Star Wars Episode
nine no coincidence that they're
referencing ancient Jedi Mandalorian
Wars in the series because like they
reference for ceiling on the Mandalorian
then a couple days later you see it
happen during Star Wars Episode nine
they referenced the ancient Jedi
Mandalorian Wars at thousands of years
ago they also just canonized Darth Revan
from Knights of the Old Republic during
Star Wars rise of Skywalker in the next
Star Wars movie is reportedly going to
be set during the past now not the
distant past of the Old Republic era but
the period they're calling the High
Republic era the height of the Republic
hundreds of years ago I know it sounds a
little confusing what's the difference
between the Republic the Old Republic in
the New Republic because there are three
different organizations the Old Republic
era ended around five thousand years ago
with the fall of the Old Republic that's
when the final wars between the
Mandalorians and the Jedi started the
Mandalorian Crusaders used the fall of
the Old Republic as an opportunity to
strike out in a bid to claim most of the
galaxy from the Old Republic what
followed that period was what they
called the High Republic era the reason
why they don't call it the New Republic
is because a lot of this backstory in
the concept of the hybrid public was
created after they created the New
Republic era in the comics
so they'd already used the New Republic
name to define another period in time so
they just had to come up with a
different name for it the really cool
thing about this hi Republic era movie
that they're supposedly doing is it is
going to basically be a young Yoda movie
now we talked about baby Yoda but really
he's just a member of Yoda's race it's
not an actual baby version of the Yoda
character from the original trilogy but
this new Star Wars movie is said about
400 years in the past when Yoda would
actually be quite a bit younger but
after he'd been a Jedi Master for a
couple hundred years the timeline is a
little unclear exactly when Yoda became
a Jedi Master but there been a couple
instances where he's been quoted as
saying that he's been training Jedi for
almost 800 years so it just makes it
sound like he became a Jedi Master
sometime after he turned a hundred years
old which even if you assumed that he
was a very advanced force user as a
youngling just like baby Yoda is and it
took him way less time to become a Jedi
Master he's still trained for a number
of decades before actually becoming a
master most of the canonical jedi
masters that you see running around in
the movies in the series took them
between 20 and 30 years to achieve the
rank of Master obi-wan Kenobi is on the
faster end of that spectrum it took him
just a little over 20 years to achieve
the rank of Master but just to give you
a sense for Yoda's timeline in the Star
Wars universe he was born a little less
than 900 years before the Battle of
Yavin so he was around for most of what
you would consider this High Republic
era some of the really cool details
about the Jedi Mandalorian Wars were
thousands of years ago or that the wars
themselves were the reason why the
Mandalorians created their famous best
scar armor and modern armor smithing
techniques that were so much better than
the rest of the galaxy the very
practical reason that that happened is
that at the beginning of those Wars the
Mandalorians wore regular armor and were
no match for Jedi powers and weapons
their lightsabers cut through the
Mandalorian crusaders like a hot knife
through stormtrooper butter in out of
their initial failures they developed
their military customs and advanced best
scar metal smithing techniques the
reason why the best scar armor was so
special yes it looks very cool but
practically it was extra strong compared
to normal armor alloys it was highly
effective at resisting blaster fire and
it was even highly resistant to Jedi
lightsabers you all probably know the
Mandalorians fade ultimately they wound
up losing those
Wars but in the end they had refined
their armor smithing techniques to near
perfection and since then their
traditions of armor smithing haven't
changed that much in a few thousand
years so the customs that you see the
armor Smith here practicing on the
Mandalorian series are the same
traditions in way that they created
Armour thousands and thousands of years
ago the other important reason why I
think they're introducing this much Jedi
Mandalorian lore heading into season two
is because the Mandalorian himself will
find more force sensitive people capable
of training baby Yoda in the force but
it'll wind up turning into another
situation like the Mandalorian Episode
three where initially he thinks he's
fulfilling the terms of his mission by
handing baby Yoda over to these new Jedi
but winds up realizing that they're
going to be just as bad for him maybe
exploit him in a slightly different way
as bad as the Imperials like Moff Gideon
or Werner Herzog's character we're going
to do so the mando will be forced to
make a similar choice again is baby Yoda
better with them or is he better with me
as their relationship and their
father-son bond continues to grow papa
bless they'll make more announcements
about this young Yoda
Star Wars movie later this year there
were some people claiming Lucasfilm was
gonna reveal details later in January I
don't know if that's true but if they do
I'll totally do a video about it what's
gonna happen next though is next month
in February the new Clone Wars season 7
episodes will be released starting
February 17th there are 12 episodes
total that'll cover the siege of
Mandalore in the night of a thousand
tears that Moff Gideon referenced during
the Mandalore episode 8 see how I said
everything is connected
maybe Moff Gideon will also show up
during those new Clone Wars episodes
then sometime in August Marvel's Falcon
and Winter Soldier episodes will start
they'll run for six weeks then they'll
do six weeks of the wan division series
with scarlet which then by mid-november
the Mandalorian season 2 episodes will
start and they'll run through the end of
the year then because the obi-wan series
are filming their episodes this summer
they might release that right after the
Mandalorian season 2 episodes finish
I'll do more videos for everything as we
start to get more details but leave all
your requests in the comments below
everyone click here for my Mandalorian
season 2 teaser video and learn about
the dark saber and click here for my
marble New Mutants trailer video thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I have spoken